This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's hard to overstate just how important record album art was to music before we downloaded everything. Our experience with a record or CD used to be visual. The design of the record cover was your first impression of what was to come. I would stare at the fonts on the cover and pour over the liner notes the first time I put an album on.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。在一切都可以下载之前，唱片封套对音乐的重要性怎么强调都不为过。我们对唱片或CD的体验曾经是视觉上的。唱片封套的设计是你对即将听到的内容的第一印象。我第一次放一张唱片时，会盯着封面上的字体，仔细研读内页说明。
It was original. I'm not saying that era music was better. It wasn't. It was just different. The art on the records tried to encapsulate the essence of a band, and then that essence was transferred to you because you were a fan, and it became part of your identity too. At least that's what it felt like. Album art was certainly important to my friend and reporter, Sean Cole. One certain album and one certain band, in particular. Roman, were you ever a Divo fan? I was a more of a Divo appreciator.
那是原创的。我并不是说那个时代的音乐更好。并不是。只是不同而已。唱片上的艺术试图概括一个乐队的精髓，然后这种精髓被传递给你，因为你是粉丝，它也成为了你身份的一部分。至少感觉是这样。唱片艺术对我的朋友兼记者肖恩·科尔来说肯定很重要。特别是某一张特定的唱片和某一个特定的乐队。罗曼，你曾经是Divo乐队的粉丝吗？我更多是Divo的欣赏者。
I don't think I was really a fan. Like I listened to unlike the songs I heard. I remember Whip It when I was a kid. I remember they were. You were not a Divo team. No, it was not a devotee. I remember the red hats, and I have a particular memory of them doing a cover of, I can't get no satisfaction
我觉得我算不上真正的粉丝。就像我听过，但不像我听到的那些歌。我记得小时候听过《Whip It》。我记得他们是……你不是Divo的死忠粉。不，不是死忠粉。我记得那些红色的帽子，我特别记得他们翻唱了《I Can't Get No Satisfaction》。
by the rolling stones on Sardinite Live wearing these yellow hazmat suits. You know, like they were really weird. Yes, weird. Yes. So this story is about that devote album, the one that they were promoting on that Sorry Night Live performance you saw.
那是滚石乐队的歌，他们在《周六夜现场》上表演时穿着黄色的防化服。你知道，他们真的很怪。是的，怪。是的。所以这个故事就是关于那张死忠粉专辑，就是你在那次《周六夜现场》表演中看到的他们正在宣传的那张。
More specifically, it's about the album art of that record. Because the story of the image that ultimately ended up on the cover of that record is this crazy rabbit hole that I fell down. But before we get there, I just need to cover some things about Divo that you might not know. Do you know where the name comes from? I do not. So a lot of people think of divos as really silly, you know, nutty band and jumping around. But they were actually very serious and had a very considered philosophy. And that was that the human race is in a state of de-evolution, hence, Devo. So their songs are all other than Whip It. Like, their songs are mostly about corporate control
更具体地说，是关于那张唱片的封面艺术。因为最终出现在那张唱片封面上的图像背后的故事，是我陷入的一个疯狂的兔子洞。但在我们进入正题之前，我需要先介绍一些你可能不知道的关于Divo的事情。你知道这个名字的由来吗？我不知道。很多人认为Divo是一个非常傻、非常疯狂、跳来跳去的乐队。但他们实际上非常严肃，有着非常深思熟虑的哲学。那就是人类正处于“去进化”（de-evolution）的状态，因此叫Devo。所以他们的歌，除了《Whip It》之外，大多是关于企业控制
and blind conformity. And they were actually visual artists before they wrote any songs. This was in the early 70s in Akron, Ohio. So I talked with one of the founders of Devo, Jerry Kasale, who says like back then, they were mostly trying to figure out what de-evolutionary art would look like. You know, because we were very, very enamored
和盲目顺从的。而且他们在写歌之前实际上是视觉艺术家。那是在70年代初的俄亥俄州阿克伦。所以我采访了Devo的创始人之一杰里·卡萨莱，他说当时他们主要是想弄清楚“去进化艺术”会是什么样子。你知道，因为我们当时非常非常迷恋
and put off at the same time by pop culture, like the lowest end of like ad graphics, terrible TV commercials. We were kind of drawn to Kitch. And occasionally they would go out shopping for Kitch. So we're walking through the Kmart. Nope, it was the predecessor to Kmart. It was click. And this is Mark Mothersburg, he's another member of the band. This is probably the point to mention that this was more than four decades ago
同时也非常反感流行文化，比如最底层的广告图形、糟糕的电视广告。我们有点被媚俗（Kitsch）所吸引。偶尔他们会出去寻找媚俗的东西。我们走在Kmart里。不，那是Kmart的前身。是Click。这是马克·马瑟斯博，他是乐队的另一名成员。现在大概应该提到，这是四十多年前的事了
and not everybody's memory is too clear. Well, so independent of what department store they are in. They are in a department store. They are in a department store. We were looking for supplies. We were collaborating on a visual art piece together and walking through the sports section. And there's these six practice golf balls
并不是每个人的记忆都那么清晰。好吧，不管他们在哪个百货公司。他们在一家百货公司。他们在一家百货公司。我们在寻找补给。我们当时正在合作一件视觉艺术作品，走在体育用品区。那里有六个练习高尔夫球
in a clear plastic pouch sealed shut at the top with a cardboard display head. Took a new picture of this. It's like that display head with the hole in it that hangs on a hook. Yes, I can picture it. Kind of like the rocks with bags of generic candy at the gas station, like a clear bag full of candy. And it just says gummy bears at the top.
装在一个透明塑料袋里，顶部用纸板展示头密封。拍了一张这个的新照片。就像那种带孔的展示头，挂在钩子上。是的，我能想象出来。有点像加油站里装满普通糖果的袋子，就像一个装满糖果的透明袋子。顶部写着“软糖熊”。
All right, so on that display head is an illustration of the smiling face of Chichi Rodriguez. And who was Chichi Rodriguez? Chichi Rodriguez is one of the most famous golfers in history. He was like, I don't know what Chichi Rodriguez was like. He was like the Elvis of golfers. GG Rodriguez was like. He was like the Elvis of golfer. So he was just like a big show, man.
好了，那个展示头上是奇奇·罗德里格斯的笑脸插图。奇奇·罗德里格斯是谁？奇奇·罗德里格斯是历史上最著名的高尔夫球手之一。他就像是……我不知道奇奇·罗德里格斯是什么样的。他就像高尔夫球手里的猫王。奇奇·罗德里格斯就像是……他就像高尔夫球手里的猫王。所以他就像一个大表演家。
I saw it and I just loved it. It was a picture of him in front of a golf ball. So his head's kind of haloed by a big golf ball. Kind of imitating something that I'd already been printing, which was human heads in front of the moon. And it made us laugh. We chuckle. We have to have that. And of course, golf was almost symbolically
我看到了，我就爱上了它。那是他站在一个高尔夫球前的照片。所以他的头被一个大高尔夫球衬托着，像个光环。有点模仿我已经在印刷的东西，也就是月亮前的人头。这让我们笑了。我们咯咯笑。我们必须拥有它。当然，高尔夫几乎在象征意义上
like the most lame kind of, you know, bourgeois pursuit that you could have, especially at that time, unless your parents were rich, you didn't get to go golfing. If we ever imagined ourselves on a golf course, it was probably as a caddy. And how boring it looked then on TV and then announcing, but the one guy who stood out was Chi Chi,
是最无聊的、资产阶级的追求，特别是在那个时候，除非你的父母很有钱，否则你没机会去打高尔夫。如果我们想象自己在高尔夫球场上，那可能也是作为球童。当时在电视上看到它有多无聊，还有解说，但唯一脱颖而出的人是奇奇，
because he didn't fit with the rest of the golfers at all. He wore these loud pants and bright shirts, and he had this famous hat that only he wore, which had a specific hat band and you know, Panama hat. You know, Panama, Panama kind of hat. Yeah. So did they buy those golf balls?
因为他根本不适合其他高尔夫球手。他穿着那些花哨的裤子和鲜艳的衬衫，他还有那顶只有他戴的著名帽子，有特定的帽带，你知道，巴拿马帽。你知道，巴拿马，巴拿马那种帽子。是的。那么他们买那些高尔夫球了吗？
They bought the golf balls. Mark used the Chi Chi image in a manifesto he was writing about being a quote unquote spud boy in the rubber town of Akron. But other than that, nothing really happened with it until we were already putting out our self-produced single, Be Stiff. Oh, I like that song. It's, this is my favorite one. And so it's like this kind of joky anthem, celebrating literal stiffness, like uptightness,
他们买了那些高尔夫球。马克在他写的一篇关于在阿克伦橡胶城做一个所谓的“土豆男孩”（spud boy）的宣言中使用了奇奇的形象。但除此之外，直到我们发行我们自制的单曲《Be Stiff》之前，并没有发生什么。哦，我喜欢那首歌。这是我最喜欢的一首。所以它就像是一种讽刺的赞歌，赞美字面上的“僵硬”，也就是紧张，
talking about televangelist, politicians, and how stiff they are. Somehow, and I don't really remember the moment, but we had the idea of putting Chi Chi on that cover. And so they used that picture of Chi Chi on the cover of the 45 of the single. And it was like this commentary on commercialism and our obsession with selling.
谈论电视布道者、政客，以及他们有多僵硬。不知何故，我不记得那一刻了，但我们有了把奇奇放在封面上的想法。所以他们把那张奇奇的照片用在了单曲的45转唱片封面上。这就像是对商业主义和我们对销售的痴迷的一种评论。
And in this case, selling plastic golf balls and the Americana of the golfer. So B-Step comes out in 1978 and there's still not famous. They're in the Subscure Art Rock Band. But then about four months later, Devo gets their big break. Warner Brothers signed the band to their first full-length album. And that, according to Jerry, is where the real D-Evolution began. We've laid that whole thing out and working up to this moment
在这种情况下，是销售塑料高尔夫球和高尔夫球手的美式文化。所以《Be Stiff》在1978年发行，他们当时还不红。他们是一个默默无闻的艺术摇滚乐队。但大约四个月后，Devo迎来了他们的重大突破。华纳兄弟签下了他们，发行了他们的第一张全长专辑。据杰里说，真正的“去进化”就是从那里开始的。我们已经铺垫了这一切，并为这一刻做准备
and then comes the real Devo twist that only a corporation could provide. In other words, what we're talking about, we become part of. So there are about to be on top 40 radio and broadcasts on the TV screens of Middle America. What was that first record called? It's a long title. It's called Question.
然后是只有大公司才能提供的真正的Devo式转折。换句话说，我们所谈论的，我们成为了其中的一部分。所以他们即将出现在40大电台和美国中部的电视屏幕上。那张第一张唱片叫什么名字？标题很长。叫《Question》。
Are we? Question? Are we not men? Answer. We are Devo. And this is their first major label album. This is their first, yeah, I know exactly right. So Mark and Jerry and the other members of the band,
Are we? Question? Are we not men? Answer. We are Devo. 这是他们的第一张大厂牌专辑。这是他们的第一张，是的，我知道，完全正确。所以马克和杰里以及乐队的其他成员，
they're like, well, that picture of Chi Chi worked so well on the single, let's just stick with it. You know, it's kind of our brand now. Let's just put that on the cover of the full length record. And this is like a picture of Chishi Rodriguez, the original picture from that thing they bought at Kmart, they just took that, lifted it directly, and put it onto their album, and they're gonna put that now on a major label album.
他们想，好吧，那张奇奇的照片在单曲上效果很好，我们就坚持用它吧。你知道，这现在算是我们的品牌了。我们就把它放在全长唱片的封面上。这就是奇奇·罗德里格斯的照片，他们从Kmart买的那东西上的原始照片，他们直接拿过来，原封不动地放到了他们的专辑上，他们现在要把它放在一张大厂牌专辑上。
Okay. Yeah. Okay. So they head to California, you know, movie, montage, the music here, here, Beverly Hill, Belize, whatever. And they go to Warner Brothers HQ. And this is like the process back then. And maybe now I don't know.
好的。是的。好的。所以他们前往加利福尼亚，你知道，电影，蒙太奇，这里的音乐，这里，比佛利山庄，等等。他们去了华纳兄弟总部。这就是当时的流程。也许现在也是，我不知道。
But like they're heading from department to department and Warner Brothers, you know, dealing with all of the new album things that need to happen. We're told to go see, I think, Rick Serini was his name and he seemed to be an okay guy. He's in the art department. Yeah. He's the head of the art department.
但他们从一个部门走到另一个部门，在华纳兄弟，你知道，处理所有需要发生的新专辑事情。我们被告知去见，我想，里克·塞里尼是他的名字，他看起来是个不错的人。他在艺术部门。是的。他是艺术部门的负责人。
I was creative director at Warner Bros. Records. He seemed to like what we were up to. The one band that I appreciated the most was Devo. I love the fact that they just never took anything very seriously. Do you remember that first meeting with them? I'm not alone. Do I remember to have a polaroid of it? We show him the image.
我是华纳兄弟唱片的创意总监。他似乎喜欢我们正在做的事情。我最欣赏的一支乐队是Devo。我喜欢他们从不把任何事情看得太严肃这一点。你还记得第一次见他们吗？我不孤单。我记得我有一张拍立得照片。我们给他看了那张图。
He chuckles. I thought it was clip art. Yeah. Chi Chi does look a lot like clip art. And I guess I never asked. I only found out that it was him sometime later. I guess what did it, I guess what did it evoke for you? Obserty. I mean, you have to think about what was going on back in the day.
他咯咯笑。我以为那是剪贴画。是的，奇奇看起来确实很像剪贴画。我想我从来没问过。我后来才知道那是他。我想，它让你想到了什么？荒谬。我的意思是，你必须想想当时发生了什么。
Artwork, you know, on album covers had rules attached to it. Most of the albums were delivered to little mom pop music stores all around the country. Right. And there'd be some kid who would come in at four o'clock after school. And his job was to open up the box of records from Warner Brothers or Columbia or whatnot and then rack them, right? So the one thing that they told all of us in the art department is don't screw that up. A rock band has to look like a rock band,
艺术作品，你知道，在专辑封面上是有规则的。大多数专辑被送到全国各地的小型家庭音乐商店。对吧。会有个孩子在放学后四点钟进来。他的工作是打开华纳兄弟或哥伦比亚唱片公司之类的唱片箱，然后把它们上架，对吧？所以艺术部门告诉我们所有人的唯一一件事就是不要搞砸。摇滚乐队必须看起来像摇滚乐队，
a country western has to look like country western. They better have cowboy hats on. Otherwise, they get misracked and then if people can't find them in the rack of the genre they're interested in, they don't buy it. But in Devo's case, the music was so unusual that it could have something completely absurd on the cover and make perfect sense. that it could have something completely absurd on the cover and make perfect sense. So even though it makes no sense that a picture of a flamboyant golfer stolen from a package of golf balls,
乡村音乐必须看起来像乡村音乐。他们最好戴上牛仔帽。否则，它们会被放错架子，如果人们在他们感兴趣的流派架子上找不到它们，他们就不会买。但在Devo的案例中，音乐是如此不同寻常，以至于封面上可以有完全荒谬的东西，而且完全说得通。所以即使把一张从高尔夫球包装上偷来的浮夸高尔夫球手的照片作为Devo的吉祥物毫无意义，
is the mascot of Devo. It does make perfect sense because that's who Devo is. It was just like pick something impossible. And Rick is just psyched. Like he loves working on this on this with them. They're you know it's they're doing all the little design things then giving them like the font with the double bold and the the you know all the stuff and you know getting getting everything ready. He laid it all out, speck the colors, you know did the whole series thing
它确实完全说得通，因为这就是Devo。这就像是选一些不可能的东西。里克非常兴奋。他喜欢和他们一起做这个。他们正在做所有的小设计，然后给他们像那种加粗字体，你知道，所有这些东西，你知道，把一切准备好。他把一切都排版好，标出颜色，你知道，做了整个系列
where they give you a transparency that's a mock-up, right? And we approve it. And then about two days later, we get this call, and it's a big crisis. The call was from the vice president of Business Affairs for Warner Brothers. David Burman, who was a guy that you would cast in a movie about the music business? As the villain, as the hero? Well, it just depends on your point of view. It was very smart, very good at what he did and played a hard ball. And the first communication is, I'm a golfer
他们给你一张透明胶片作为样稿，对吧？我们批准了。然后大约两天后，我们接到了这个电话，这是一个大危机。电话是华纳兄弟商业事务副总裁打来的。大卫·伯曼，一个你会选去演一部关于音乐产业电影的人？作为反派，还是英雄？嗯，这取决于你的观点。他非常聪明，非常擅长他的工作，而且手段强硬。第一次沟通是，我是个高尔夫球手
and I'm a fan of golf and I know Chi Chi Rodriguez. I've met Chi Chi Rodriguez. You cannot use Chi sheet ride regas. That is completely and totally false. This is David Burman. I told you not everybody's memory is crystal clear regarding this story. Not only have I never, I have never seen cheat sheet ride regas other than on television. I'm not going to make fun of a friend of mine.
我是高尔夫球迷，我认识奇奇·罗德里格斯。我见过奇奇·罗德里格斯。你不能使用奇奇·罗德里格斯。这是完全彻底错误的。这是大卫·伯曼。我告诉过你，并不是每个人的记忆都对这个故事记得一清二楚。我不仅从来没有，我除了在电视上之外从来没见过奇奇·罗德里格斯。我不会去取笑我的朋友。
You never met him. I've never spoken to him. I'm not going to get this company sued. That part is accurate, says David Burman, about maybe being sued. Yes, he did play hardball, but he says his objection was purely a legal one. Purely. In California law, it's crystal clear. You can't use somebody's name or likeness for commercial purposes without their permission. He had nothing to do with my being a golfer, other than because I was. I knew that it was clearly Cheechy Rodriguez,
你从来没见过他。我从来没跟他说过话。我不会让这家公司被起诉。大卫·伯曼说，关于可能被起诉的那部分是准确的。是的，他确实手段强硬，但他说是他的反对纯粹是法律上的。纯粹是。在加州法律中，这非常明确。未经许可，你不能将某人的姓名或肖像用于商业目的。他和我作为高尔夫球手没有任何关系，除了因为我是。我知道那显然是奇奇·罗德里格斯，
but it wasn't the fact that he was likable. It could have been Rory Sabatini and I would have done the same thing. Wait, who is Rory Sabatini? He's a golfer. Uh-huh. But nobody likes Rory Sabatini. Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
但这并不是因为他讨人喜欢。换成罗里·萨巴蒂尼，我也会做同样的事。等等，罗里·萨巴蒂尼是谁？他是个高尔夫球手。嗯。但没人喜欢罗里·萨巴蒂尼。哈哈哈哈。
Why does nobody like Rory Sabatini? I don't know. Also, Rory Sabatini was born in 1976 and would have been two years old when this diva record came out. But anyway, this all came as a real blow to the band. We're dumbfounded and crestfallen. We don't know what to do. And, but of course, we're stubborn. We're not giving up. So they're like, let's just write Chi Chi a letter and ask his permission. But in the meantime,
为什么没人喜欢罗里·萨巴蒂尼？我不知道。而且，罗里·萨巴蒂尼出生于1976年，这张Devo唱片出来的时候他才两岁。但无论如何，这对乐队来说是一个真正的打击。我们目瞪口呆，垂头丧气。我们不知道该怎么办。但是，当然，我们很固执。我们不会放弃。所以他们想，我们就给奇奇写封信，请求他的许可吧。但与此同时，
you know, the corporate gears are rolling and money's been paid and, you know, Warner Brothers is expecting a product. So, Divos like, let's come up with a plan B, and they had this idea that actually involves another piece of D evolutionary art. It's an artist rendering of what the last four presidents would have looked like had you combined them. So Ford, Nixon, Johnson, and Kennedy, all of their faces, mashed together. Mark Mothers' Bud just had this picture lying around. And it was this hideous, bizarre face that had John Kennedy's hairline, and it had Lyndon Johnson's ears and Richard Nixon's nose.
你知道，公司的齿轮在转动，钱已经付了，你知道，华纳兄弟在期待产品。所以Devo想，我们想个B计划吧，他们有个想法，实际上涉及另一件“去进化”艺术作品。这是最后四位总统如果组合在一起会是什么样子的艺术家渲染图。所以福特、尼克松、约翰逊和肯尼迪，他们所有的脸，拼凑在一起。马克·马瑟斯博刚好有这张照片。那是一张丑陋、怪异的脸，有约翰·肯尼迪的发际线，有林登·约翰逊的耳朵和理查德·尼克松的鼻子。
So the band brings that image to the Warner Brothers' art department. On an idea that why couldn't we just mutate Chi Chi's face? So that it isn't Chi Chi anymore. So what did they end up doing to Chi Chi's face? So they basically, like, it was like building a Mr. Potato Head toy, like they grafted Johnson's ears and Nixon's nose on the cheeky's head and reverse the mouth. I should actually, I should say that David Berman
所以乐队把那张图带到了华纳兄弟的艺术部门。基于一个想法，为什么我们不能直接变异奇奇的脸？这样它就不再是奇奇了。所以他们最后对奇奇的脸做了什么？所以他们基本上，就像，就像拼装“土豆头先生”玩具，他们把约翰逊的耳朵和尼克松的鼻子嫁接到奇奇的头上，并反转了嘴巴。我实际上应该说，大卫·伯曼
who was in business affairs at the time, he doesn't remember the image being altered. So I sent him the original cheeky image from the golf balls and the potato head collage just so he could compare them. Looking at it today, I wonder why I proved it because to me it still looks like Gigi, but obviously I must have. And here's Jerry Cassali. About three weeks later, a letter comes back from Chi Chi's representatives.
当时在商业事务部，他不记得图像被修改过。所以我把高尔夫球上的原始奇奇图像和土豆头拼贴画发给了他，这样他就可以比较它们。今天看着它，我想知道我为什么批准了它，因为对我来说它看起来仍然像奇奇，但显然我一定批准了。这是杰里·卡萨莱。大约三周后，奇奇的代表回信了。
No. Saying, yes, Chi Chi thinks it's fine to use that image. He just wants 50 records at Christmas time to give out to his friends and family. He wanted to say to his friends and family, like, look, I'm on a record. Right. He liked that. And this is Mark Mother's Ball.
不。说，是的，奇奇认为使用那个图像没问题。他只是想要50张唱片在圣诞节送给他的朋友和家人。他想对他的朋友和家人说，看，我在一张唱片上。对。他喜欢那样。这是马克·马瑟斯博。
And so at that point, it's like, we couldn't go back. They'd already printed the cover so now we had this mutilated potato face for an album cover And it didn't really look like the handsome cheat sheet anymore So I'm sure he was quite surprised when he got a box of him in the mail all our efforts were in fact in earnest But what it looked like in the end is that divo had mainly tricked But what it looked like in the end is that Devo had mainly tricked Chichi Rai Riegas and put out something that made him look hideous.
所以在那一点上，就像，我们无法回头了。他们已经印好了封面，所以现在我们有了一张被毁容的土豆脸作为专辑封面，它看起来确实不再像英俊的奇奇了。所以我敢肯定，当他收到一箱自己的照片时，他一定很惊讶。我们所有的努力实际上都是真诚的。但最终看起来，Devo主要是欺骗了
It was a mess. Now, they did send Chichi a couple thousand dollars also as well as the records. It wasn't the total loss for him, but then they just, they never heard from him again. Wow. So they never got his take on the outmart or even the songs on the album or anything like that. Which is my reigning question in all of this. I really want to know if Chi Chi ever listened to that record and what he thought of it.
奇奇·罗德里格斯，并发布了一些让他看起来很丑陋的东西。这是一团糟。现在，他们确实也给了奇奇几千美元以及唱片。对他来说这不是完全的损失，但后来他们就再也没有收到他的消息了。哇。所以他们从来没有得到他对封面艺术甚至专辑中歌曲的看法，或者类似的东西。这是我所有这些问题中的主要问题。我真的很想知道奇奇是否听过那张唱片，以及他怎么看它。
Yeah, that would be the big question. Well, why don't you interview Chi Chi Rodriguez? Hello. Hello, Chi Chi Rodriguez. Yeah, who's this? It's Sean Cole. He reached Chi Chi at a country club, naturally. In West Palm Beach, Florida, he's in his early 80s now,
是的，那将是最大的问题。好吧，你为什么不采访奇奇·罗德里格斯呢？你好。你好，奇奇·罗德里格斯。是的，你是谁？我是肖恩·科尔。他自然是在一家乡村俱乐部联系到奇奇的。在佛罗里达州西棕榈滩，他现在80多岁了，
still handsome, still plays golf, not professionally. Does a lot of philanthropic work through his foundation and an annual charity event. It's really an honor to talk to you. It's my honor to talk to you, Johnny. It's Sean, but that's okay. Oh, he sounds like the best, Johnny. I love him. He's so sweet.
依然英俊，依然打高尔夫球，不是职业的。通过他的基金会和年度慈善活动做了很多慈善工作。真的很荣幸能和你交谈。我很荣幸能和你交谈，约翰尼。我是肖恩，但没关系。哦，他听起来像个最好的人，约翰尼。我爱他。他太甜了。
I love him. Chichi says he remembers getting this letter and he says he did give out those records to his friends and family. Did you notice when you got the record that it didn't quite look like you that much? Well, it looked like me. I look at the process. It looked like me a little bit. At least, at least, the hat looked like me. But he didn't know anything about them messing with his face. And he had no idea that they were worried he was going to sue them.
我爱他。奇奇说他记得收到这封信，他说他确实把那些唱片送给了他的朋友和家人。当你收到唱片时，你有没有注意到它看起来不太像你？嗯，它看起来像我。我看那个过程。它看起来有点像我。至少，至少，帽子看起来像我。但他不知道他们弄乱了他的脸。而且他根本不知道他们担心他会起诉他们。
Sue them. Well, anybody that worried about somebody somebody suing them, that means that they're so crooked that they sue people and they think that people have a sue them. I thought it was this young people trying to make a career out of it and I could help them. And that's it, because I like to do something good every day of my life.
起诉他们。好吧，任何担心别人起诉他们的人，这意味着他们自己很狡猾，所以他们起诉别人，他们认为别人也会起诉他们。我以为是这些年轻人试图以此为生，我可以帮助他们。就是这样，因为我喜欢每天做点好事。
And I want to leave the earth, better than I found it. So even young sort of avant-garde punk musicians you want to help? Yeah. Did you listen to that record? Yeah. I listened to it one time just once. I put her away. You didn't like it. No, I didn't like it. I like Traction Atre and Nath King Cole and Dave Martin, who was my favorite, you know? Because music is not supposed to rally up. Music is something to bring you down. So the most important question answered.
我想让地球比我发现它时更好。所以即使是年轻的先锋朋克音乐家你也想帮助？是的。你听过那张唱片吗？是的。我听过一次，就一次。我把它收起来了。你不喜欢它。不，我不喜欢它。我喜欢特拉西·阿特雷和纳特·金·科尔和戴夫·马丁，那是我的最爱，你知道吗？因为音乐不应该是让人兴奋的。音乐是让你平静下来的东西。所以最重要的问题得到了回答。
He did not like it. Right. But as I was talking to him, I was like, well, there's like a kind of greater question here, which is like, like what did he think about his face or a mutated version thereof? Being on the cover of this apocalyptic, weirdo art rock bands first record, like did that, like did that make sense to him.
他不喜欢它。对。但当我和他交谈时，我想，好吧，这里有一个更大的问题，那就是，他怎么看他的脸或其变异版本？出现在这个末日、怪异的艺术摇滚乐队的第一张唱片封面上，这对他来说有意义吗？
And it did in a way, because because Chichi knows he's Chichi. He knows how much he stands out. And how outlandish he is. None of that is lost on him. And in fact, he said it's purposeful. Golf is show business. And when you're on stage, you got to give the people a show. And that's what the people came out and gave the people a good time.
在某种程度上是有意义的，因为奇奇知道他是奇奇。他知道他有多突出。他有多古怪。这些他都知道。事实上，他说这是有目的的。高尔夫是演艺事业。当你站在舞台上时，你必须给人们一场表演。这就是人们出来并给人们美好时光的原因。
So that is the similarity between you and Devo? Yes. So in a way, it really makes sense that they used you on the cover of their record. I think they were geniuses. And it takes a genius to recognize another. Whoa, you guys sound almost diabolical there. Yes, me and Chi Chi, the bottom of Ovalcano, planning the evolution of the human race. The evolution of the human race, exactly.
所以这就是你和Devo之间的相似之处？是的。所以从某种意义上说，他们在唱片封面上使用你确实很有意义。我认为他们是天才。而天才才能识别另一个天才。哇，你们听起来几乎很邪恶。是的，我和奇奇，在奥瓦尔卡诺底部，计划人类的进化。人类的进化，没错。
One could argue that, again, Jerry Cassali, what we were put through by David Burman, actually achieved something here better than just using a found image. So what you're saying is corporate interference plus the faces of four American presidents who prosecuted the Vietnam War, and it's aftermath, and this wonderfully dandy-ish golf legend,
有人可能会争辩说，再次提到杰里·卡萨莱，大卫·伯曼让我们经历的一切，实际上在这里取得了一些比仅仅使用现成图像更好的成就。所以你的意思是企业干预加上四位发动越南战争的美国总统的脸，以及它的后果，还有这位奇妙的、花花公子般的高尔夫传奇，
all of those together. Yeah, it's more devo than the original Chi Chi image in a way. That's what I'm saying. It's devo and action. Like, do you need an example of what we're talking about? Here it is. like you need an example of what we're talking about, here it is. So this whole story takes place at the beginning of Debo's career, and they go on to play for decades, it's extremely famous.
所有这些加在一起。是的，从某种意义上说，它比原始的奇奇图像更Devo。这就是我所说的。这是Devo在行动。就像，你需要一个我们所谈论的例子吗？就在这里。所以整个故事发生在Devo职业生涯的开始，他们继续表演了几十年，非常出名。
They were just nominated to be in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame. Do they think about Chi Chi as part of their origin story? You know, Mark Mothersbach actually sort of raised that when we were talking. I really, I don't think anybody ever tried to measure how much that album cover had in the success of Divo, but it could possibly have been the tipping stone that just like changed everything
他们刚刚被提名进入摇滚名人堂。他们认为奇奇是他们起源故事的一部分吗？你知道，马克·马瑟斯博在我们交谈时确实提到了这一点。我真的，我不认为有人试图衡量那张专辑封面在Devo的成功中占了多少，但它可能是改变一切的转折点
and gave us a chance to have a public career. So just in case, thank you, Chi Chi. Hey, Roman. Yeah. Stories not over. There's one more diabolical divot twist, a year's Dirk Asali. I have to say that now that I'm a senior citizen,
并给了我们一个拥有公共职业生涯的机会。所以以防万一，谢谢你，奇奇。嘿，罗曼。是的。故事还没结束。还有一个邪恶的Devo转折，听听杰里·卡萨莱。我必须说，现在我是一个老年人了，
I completely changed my attitude about the game of golf. You did not, really? Yeah, I like it now. I really, it's changed so much from those days and who got to play it and how it's played. I mean, those guys really are athletes. I never thought I would hear a member of Devo say that. I know.
我完全改变了我对高尔夫运动的态度。你没有，真的吗？是的，我现在喜欢它了。它真的和那些日子相比改变了很多，谁能玩它以及它是怎么玩的。我的意思是，那些家伙确实是运动员。我从没想过我会听到Devo的成员这么说。我知道。
Oh, here's a double-e, hideous secret, unfolding right now. I really like professional football. Okay. A version of this piece originally aired on the NBR Sports Show only a game, special thanks to Gary Wallach who who conceived of the story, and Hugh Brown, who helped Sean Cole with the research. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Around the time Divo was putting out there for singles in the mid 1970s,
哦，这是一个双重、可怕的秘密，现在正在展开。我真的很喜欢职业橄榄球。好的。这个片段的一个版本最初在NPR体育节目《Only a Game》中播出，特别感谢构思这个故事的加里·沃拉克，以及帮助肖恩·科尔进行研究的休·布朗。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 在Devo在70年代中期发行他们的单曲时，
a music teacher in Canada was making his own DIY records with a bunch of his elementary school students, and the result was a haunting and uplifting outsider or masterpiece. That story, after this. In Canada, in the 1970s, a music teacher named Hans Finger recorded 60 of his elementary school students singing in a gymnasium. He pressed a few vinyl records of those recordings and handed them out to parents. The Langley School Music Project was little known until a record collector named Brian
加拿大的一位音乐老师正在和一群小学生制作他自己的DIY唱片，结果是一部令人难忘且令人振奋的局外人杰作。那个故事，在这之后。在70年代的加拿大，一位名叫汉斯·芬格的音乐老师录制了60名小学生在体育馆唱歌的录音。他压制了几张这些录音的黑胶唱片，并分发给家长。兰利学校音乐项目在2000年被一位名叫布莱恩·林德的唱片收藏家在旧货店发现其中一张专辑之前鲜为人知。
Linde found one of those albums in a thrift store in the year 2000. Land shared it with some people and eventually bar non-records gave it a proper release. The records cover featured a collage of black and white pictures of the students singing, strumming guitars, playing drums, and clapping along. The album was called Innocence and Despair. The rediscovered recordings were a hit. Slán music critic Stephen Heiden wrote, The gloomy title Innocence and Despair is no lie.
兰德与一些人分享了它，最终Bar None唱片公司给了它一个正式的发行。唱片封面是一张黑白照片拼贴画，展示了学生们唱歌、弹吉他、打鼓和拍手。这张专辑叫《Innocence and Despair》。这些被重新发现的录音很受欢迎。音乐评论家斯蒂芬·海登写道，《Innocence and Despair》这个阴郁的标题并非谎言。
The echoing, yolping renditions of this feel-good music gives off a powerfully aching melancholy. It's the sound of youth, frozen on tape, as it fades inexorably away. Here's the music teacher from the Langley School Music project Hans Finger, talking to Katie Mingle in 2010. Before I was teaching in Langley, I played in a heavy metal band. It never occurred to me to be a teacher.
这种感觉良好的音乐的回声、叫喊的演绎散发出一种强烈的痛苦忧郁。这是青春的声音，冻结在磁带上，随着它无情地消逝。这是兰利学校音乐项目的音乐老师汉斯·芬格，在2010年与凯蒂·明格尔交谈。在我去兰利教书之前，我在一支重金属乐队里演奏。我从来没想过要当老师。
I was a really good student myself. And the kids were OK, but I wasn't all that gushy about them, to be honest with you. I knew nothing about kids music, I knew nothing about teaching, I knew nothing about anything. You know I had hair, I had attitude, I weighed hippy-dippy. I had really no philosophy at all about teaching. I had, I can't really say, I thought about it a lot, you know. I had a lot of ideas about music, but certainly not about teaching. You know, for me, I mean, I've been playing in bands since I was like 11 or 12 years old, and it wasn't like anyone he taught us.
我自己曾经是个非常好的学生。孩子们还可以，但老实说，我并没有对他们那么热情。我对儿童音乐一无所知，我对教学一无所知，我对任何事情都一无所知。你知道我有头发，我有态度，我有点嬉皮士。我根本没有任何教学哲学。我，我真的不能说，我思考了很多，你知道。我对音乐有很多想法，但肯定不是关于教学。你知道，对我来说，我的意思是，我从11或12岁起就在乐队里演奏，并不是有人教我们。
It wasn't even like anybody said, oh, this is the way you do it or that's the way you do it. We just sort of did it. And I've been doing music like that since I was a little kid. So when I went into teaching music, it never occurred to me that I was going to teach anybody how to read notes, or that I was going to teach anybody how to read notes or that I was going to teach anybody how to pass a test. The only thing I ever tried to teach children is really, it's just to fall in love with making music.
甚至没有人说，哦，这是你做的方法，或者那是你做的方法。我们只是做了。我从小就一直在那样做音乐。所以当我开始教音乐时，我从来没想过我要教任何人如何读谱，或者我要教任何人如何通过考试。我唯一尝试教给孩子们的，真的，只是爱上制作音乐。
But that was always my goal. I just thought songs I knew and I was very into David Bowie in those days. I was very into Iggy Pop. I was into Phil's old Phil Spector records, Brian Wilson, and it wasn't until much later that I realized that the songs were thematic. You know, I had gotten a teaching job originally because I was with my girlfriend and she was having a baby and I needed a day job. And by the time I got this job, we were breaking up. And I think that in the back of my mind, you know, I was feeling like a little bit lost.
但这一直是我的目标。我只是想到了我知道的歌，而且我当时非常迷恋大卫·鲍伊。我非常迷恋伊基·波普。我迷恋菲尔·斯佩克特的旧唱片，布莱恩·威尔逊，直到很久以后我才意识到这些歌是有主题的。你知道，我最初得到这份教学工作是因为我和我的女朋友在一起，她怀孕了，我需要一份日常工作。当我得到这份工作时，我们正在分手。我想在我的脑海深处，你知道，我感觉有点迷失。
In my room, in my room, in my room. Contrary to what people think, a lot of kids aren't that happy. They all have troubles. They've got problems at home, they can feel lonely, they can feel isolated, and the music can conjure up that feeling into them. Now whether or not they completely literally understand the words, I'm not sure if she's that so important. I don't think put your senses? You'll be a drug in things so long now
与人们认为的相反，很多孩子并不那么快乐。他们都有烦恼。他们在家里有困难，他们会感到孤独，他们会感到孤立，音乐可以唤起他们那种感觉。现在他们是否完全字面上理解歌词，我不确定这是否那么重要。我不认为……
But you're a hard one But I know that you got your reason This thing's a whole place And you're the person so how When I heard other school choirs and things, we sounded so different and so weird, you know Then I thought, oh well, we can't be any good I mean, listen to all those people, they really know how to sing So I never thought of it in terms of if it was special because it was good. I also thought of it in terms of if it was special because it was different. I did a lot of people, that day I, that day I,
但我知道你有你的理由。这东西是个完整的地方，而你是那个人，所以怎么……当我听到其他学校合唱团之类的东西时，我们听起来如此不同，如此怪异，你知道。然后我想，哦，好吧，我们肯定好不到哪去。我的意思是，听听那些人，他们真的知道怎么唱歌。所以我从来没想过它是否特别，因为它很好。我也想过它是否特别，因为它不同。
that day I did a lot of heart. Oftentimes I would have 16, 90 kids in my class, and there'd be all over the place because there was no room and we'd have instruments, and we had no equipment, so I brought in all the equipment for my band, which were huge martial amplifiers, and bass guitars,
我做了很多……那天我……那天我做了很多心血。通常我的班上有16到90个孩子，他们到处都是，因为没有空间，我们有乐器，我们没有设备，所以我带了我乐队的所有设备，那是巨大的马歇尔放大器，还有低音吉他，
and all kinds of things. The kids, of course, really liked that. So there wasn't much room, and the kids were practically on top of one another, and bass guitars and all kinds of things. The kids of course really liked that. So there wasn't much room, and kids were practically on top of one another. And I just sort of arranged them according to height. And that was it. I always felt like with my music teaching that I always wasn't outside of music teacher.
和各种各样的东西。孩子们当然非常喜欢那个。所以没有多少空间，孩子们几乎叠在一起。我只是按照身高安排他们。就是这样。我一直觉得我的音乐教学是一个局外人的音乐老师。
You know, I mean, I never really participated in a lot of the music teaching events and all that kind of stuff. I was always like a little island unto myself. You know, people always use this term like thinking outside the box and all that, but I think for me, I didn't even know there was a box, you know, I mean... It does have the sort of the children of the corn, yeah. Yeah, it does have that feeling. Well, I think we were kind of like a little cult, you know. So it became kind of a kind of an underground hit in New York.
你知道，我的意思是，我从来没有真正参加过很多音乐教学活动之类的东西。我一直像是一个孤岛。你知道，人们总是用“跳出框框思考”之类的词，但我认为对我来说，我甚至不知道有一个框框，你知道，我的意思是……它确实有一种“玉米田的孩子”的感觉，是的。是的，它确实有那种感觉。好吧，我想我们有点像一个小邪教，你知道。所以它在纽约变成了一种地下热门。
Tony Fisconti, who was David Bowie's producer, had heard it. And I think he thought it was a new wave band from New Jersey. And he couldn't quite believe it was a bunch of little kids from some farm is in time. You've been in my friend. And the papers want to know who you should be. Yeah, I have students that still do music to this day. They're always in touch with me. I jam with some of them once in a while. I felt that the whole success of this was a really
大卫·鲍伊的制作人托尼·维斯康蒂听到了它。我想他以为这是新泽西州的一支新浪潮乐队。他简直不敢相信这是一群来自农场的孩子。
vindicating kind of experience. It made me feel really like, wow, I can't do something. So it was great. I mean, you know, I'd always taught my students in a really positive way and then when somebody suddenly is positive about what you're doing like that, it gives you a great feeling. I'm the same, but I'm getting in a better mood You're so good to me And I love it, I love it La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la That story was produced by a former executive producer Katie Mingle in 2010 for the re-sound podcast. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole and Mith Fitzgerald and Katie Mingle, mixed by Schrefusif, Music by Swan Rihau.
是的，我有学生至今还在做音乐。他们一直和我保持联系。我偶尔会和他们中的一些人即兴演奏。我觉得这一切的成功是一种非常平反的经历。它让我感觉真的，哇，我能做点什么。所以这很棒。我的意思是，你知道，我一直以一种非常积极的方式教我的学生，然后当有人突然对你所做的事情感到积极时，这会给你一种很棒的感觉。那个故事是由前执行制片人凯蒂·明格尔在2010年为《Re-Sound》播客制作的。《99% Invisible》本周由肖恩·科尔、米斯·菲茨杰拉德和凯蒂·明格尔制作，由Schrefusif混音，音乐由Swan Rihau创作。
Kathy too is our executive producer Deline Hall is the senior editor Kurt Colstet is the digital director Residine includes Chris Barrupe, Jason Dillion, Arteen Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Boschemadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，德琳·霍尔是高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监。制作团队包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、杰森·迪利恩、阿廷·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·勒、博什马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格和我，罗曼·马斯。《99% Invisible》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。
We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family. Now, hit quartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999PI.org. On Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too.
我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在，总部位于潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@999PI.org。在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上也可以。
You can find links to others to your shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pion.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在99pion.org找到我喜欢的其他节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。